JANET RANKIN: One
active learning strategy
that I use in 595
are called mud cards.
And they are a really
easy activity to use.
Anyone can implement them,
and it's a really low barrier.
So I like to introduce
that early in the class
so that students can see
that it doesn't necessarily
disrupt the class flow.
It doesn't really
take a lot of prep.
It doesn't take a
lot of resources.
So a mud card is, at
minimum, is an index card.
And at the end of
every class, I ask
them to write down on the
index card what they might want
to know more about, what
they're still confused about,
or something that they
found particularly
compelling or interesting.
I ask them to specify that so
that I know if they just say,
active learning, I don't
know whether they thought
it was really interesting
or whether they
thought it was confusing.
So I asked them to specify.
But we use we use that because--
and then I also talk to them
about why it's so effective.
They're able to anonymously
identify what they understood
or what they're
still confused about.
I can go back to my
office afterwards,
I can look through the cards.
I can sort them out really
quickly, even in a large class,
and I've used them in
a class of 100 people,
even though 595
is just around 15.
And generally speaking, the
cards fall in three categories.
You get three main problems.
And so you know that
maybe you didn't
do a very good job of
helping students understand
a particular topic, or that
students are really interested
and want more information
about something.
I know that really
easily, really quickly.
So I can make a decision to
either get more resources,
write something up that I can
post on our course website,
or I can come to
class the next time
and say, hey, looks
like most of you
were confused about X.
Let's talk a little bit more
about that.
And I can prepare
ahead of time and be
totally ready to go in
with multiple explanations
or multiple examples
of whatever it
is people are confused about.
I looked over some of the mud
cards we had from last time
and there were some really good
questions, some really good
points.
Someone asked if all those
learning theories that we
discussed were equally valid.
They get they get
targeted feedback based
on what they don't understand.
And it's really easy.
It takes two minutes
at the end of class.
I have a colleague who
calls them tickets to leave,
meaning he doesn't let people
leave the class until they've
handed him an index card
with something on it.
But they're very,
very effective.
I believe they were first used
in the Aero-Astro department
here at MIT, but they're
used all over the place now
and they're extremely,
extremely effective.
For instructors
that are thinking
about using mud cards
in their classes,
I would say the biggest
issue or the biggest concern
would be to make sure that you
use them early in the semester
and that you use them often.
If you use them one
day and then you
don't use them for another two
weeks or even another week,
students really won't
get in the pattern
of filling them out and
filling them out thoughtfully.
And they won't see the
utility, because you really
need to come back the next time
with useful information saying,
I looked at these cards.
I understand you don't get this.
Let me help you.
And that act really
encourages students
to keep filling them
out, and it's just
a win-win for everyone.